did gluten-free for about one hour no
gluten for this guy and that was lunch
sandwiches are the cornerstones of life
so one of my favorite sandwiches I'm
gonna start off right here I'm gonna do
this one on wheat bread now I like to
butter my backsides this is what you
know you get that little brown each on
the back when you throw it in the
toaster little chipotle mayo this is a
vogue mayo its Mayo basically with a
little sriracha it is the Mayo that came
on you know in the late 2000s I'm gonna
put a little bit of Dijon mustard mixed
on top of that of the Jean is gonna give
it that alright let's get a little
turkey on here this is organically
raised turkey from Turkey this is where
I make sure all of my turkey comes from
Turkey know it's gonna be interesting
here to add everyone knows a good sharp
is just the best cheese so I'm gonna cut
me a little piece there look at that
Bobby Flay fall back son Oh none of this
now ladies and gentlemen bacon we got
turkey bacon
everyone's doing turkey bacon it's in
okay I get it but if you really want
taste which is what I'm going for
let's get these let's get let's go down
in the bottle cuz that's where we got
that bacon bacon right down there mmm
yeah yeah that's gonna be good this is a
no sigil to most sandwich makers people
don't have no idea but cognac is then
you're asking me does this go on the
sandwich no it goes with this is free
all you kids out there okay uncle Cedric
says it's fine
find your dad's stash and make yourself
a good Sam I am joking or am I so yeah I
didn't normally drink this until I had
kids I used to make all my sandwiches
with you know like high high C or shots
everything is making to come back you
know what we need to do is we need to
take Shasta and put it in some kind of
cool restaurant in Brooklyn it'll be the
hottest thing it'll be like craft Shasta
you have Shafter gardens alrighty
oh you can see that from here all right
now look at what we have here bacon look
at that chatter nice melt it down there
because I like myself just spicy and
then I want a little bit of fun to it so
what we have here is some red pepper
jelly takes your taste buds on this
crazy rollercoaster ride it's like oh my
god this is crazy
take a picture of me for Instagram while
I bite my sandwich gonna lay a few
tomatoes on this you put the pickle here
give me a good little attitude and then
some less superweapon guys I always add
a couple of Doritos in on this sandwich
always not just use any you Cool Ranch
people out there ok jump off a bridge
never Cool Ranch oh and I'm just gonna
show you the inside of that sandwich
look at that this is a Saturday
entertainer
grown-ass man which were mmm now as you
heard me allude a couple of times I'm
married and my wife won't let me eat
this sandwich so I'm gonna show you
another sandwich that have to eat when
the whites around
let's do here I'm gonna cut some
ciabatta make a little salmon sandwich
should probably mail in there this time
I just use a regular yellow mustard now
there is some turkey bacon left and you
won't go on the sandwich but because
it's around you eat it and it's a good
time to have a little more cognac right
now
it makes the sandwich taste so much
better
condiments here my tomato dress that up
make it nice and pretty
I'm so pretty easy and that's mom
this is a fresh Atlantic salmon from
Atlantic City so they can put it there
looks beautiful
me take that mmm ciabatta you don't want
to take your chance going in a diagonal
the wife sandwich what I like to call
the honey I'm home this is when she's
there and they go oh hey honey yeah I'm
here
look what I'm just getting a little bite
that's what I'm doing and she go what
did you make yourself and I said well a
salmon sandwich
he says that is good babe can I have a
piece of that and I'm sure like sure
look how satisfy you call it delicious I
call it delightful
have you eaten out there